SAYING NO, WE DON'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING THAT WOULD SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
WE WANT TO FOCUS ON TRUMP AT ALL
TIMES.
>> Bret: STANDBY.
MARK MEADOWS WALKING OUT,
JOINING US.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
GIVE US THE INSIDE SCOOP.
>> OBVIOUSLY IT WAS A LONG
MEETING WHERE THE PRESIDENT WAS
TALKING ABOUT NOT ONLY THE
AGENDA ON IMMIGRATION BUT WHAT
WE HAVE ACCOMPLISHED AND WHAT WE
NEED TO DO FROM HERE.
IT'S ALL ABOUT GETTING IT DONE.
HE REALLY WANTS US TO MAKE SURE
WE PUT UP 218 VOTES ON THE HOUSE
FLOOR THIS WEEK.
HE SAID HE IS BEHIND US 1000%.
OBVIOUSLY WANTS TO DEAL WITH
THIS SEPARATION ISSUE WITH
CHILDREN AT THE BORDER.
BOTH BILLS DO THAT.
THE COMPROMISE BILL OR THE
LEADERSHIP BILL IS CERTAINLY THE
ONE THAT SEEMS TO HAVE THE MOST,
THE HIGHEST PROBABILITY OF
GETTING TWO TO 18.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT WALKED
BY.
DEMOCRATS CHANTING ABOUT GETTING
FAMILIES TOGETHER.
DID THE PRESIDENT SAY THAT HE
KNOWS THAT HE CAN DO A CHANGE
HIMSELF?
HOW DID HE PLAY IT WITH THE
LEGISLATION?
>> HE DIDN'T DO THAT.
HE HAD SECRETARY NIELSEN THERE
AND OBVIOUSLY SHE WAS THERE THE
ROOM AND TALKING ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE GOT TO FIND A REAL
SOLUTION TO THIS.
THIS IS MORE A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH A LONG TIME.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT PRODUCTION OF
CHILDREN, THAT'S WHY THIS DEGREE
CAME DOWN ORIGINALLY.
THEY BELIEVE IT'S BEST WE GET A
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION.
I THINK THERE ARE SOME NARROW
BILLS IN THE HOUSE AND SENATE
THAT WILL ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
I AM HEARING CHUCK SCHUMER IS
NOT SUPPORTIVE OF ANY
LEGISLATIVE EFFORT.
>> Bret: WE REPORT ABOUT AND
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID TODAY TO
REPORTERS.
THERE IS NOT A REPUBLICAN
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION THAT
DEMOCRATS WILL SIGN ONTO.
YOUR REACTION.
>> MY REACTION IS READ THE
BILLS.
WE HAVE INTRODUCED A BILL,
SENATOR TED CRUZ HAS INTRODUCED
A BILL.
IS HE SAYING THAT THERE IS NO
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION?
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT, I THINK
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT US TO
SOLVE IT.
I'VE BEEN GETTING CALLS ALL DAY
LONG.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY WANT US
TO COME TOGETHER, DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS.
A NUMBER OF US ARE GIVING THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT.
>> Bret: I WANT TO LISTEN IN
AND SEE IF THE PRESIDENT SAYS
ANYTHING AS HE IS WITH THE HOUSE
MAJORITY LEADER, McCARTHY.
>> Reporter: MR. PRESIDENT .
>> President Trump: THESE LAWS
HAVE BEEN BROKEN FOR MANY YEARS,
DECADES.
WE HAD A GREAT MEETING.
>> Bret: REITERATING WHAT HE
SAID GOING IN, THAT THE LAWS
HAVE BEEN BROKEN FOR DECADES.
I HAD A GREAT.
DID HE TALK A LOT ABOUT
IMMIGRATION OR WAS IT A MIXED?
>> IT WAS A MIX.
HE STARTED WITH IMMIGRATION.
HE CAME BACK TO IMMIGRATION AT
THE MIDDLE AND AN KNACKERED WE
TALKED ABOUT REGULATION, WE
TALKED ABOUT THE ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS TO BRING DOWN
PREMIUMS FOR HEALTH CARE THAT HE
IS SIGNING WITH THE SECRETARY OF
LABOR.
>> Bret: IS THEIR URGENCY HERE
OR IS THIS AN ISSUE BOTH SIDES
ARE PLAYING POLITICS WITH?
>> OUR SIDE IS NOT PLAYING
POLITICS WITH IT.
I HAD MY STAFF WORKING FOR THE
WEEKEND, BUT A LEGISLATIVE FIX.
77 PAGES THAT WE WORKED AROUND
THE CLOCK TO GET INTRODUCED
TODAY.
WE DID THAT AT NOON.
IT'S ABOUT GETTING THE JOB DONE
RIGHT.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S BEEN A
POLITICAL FOOTBALL BACK AND
FORTH AND WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH PEOPLE'S LIVES, YOU'VE GOT
TO MAKE SURE YOU GET IT DONE
RIGHT.
HOPEFULLY WE WELL AND I BELIEVE
WE WELL THIS WEEK.
>> Bret: WERE REPUBLICAN
SAYING WE NEED TO DO A NARROW
BILL OR THE PRESIDENT HAS TO
CHANGE THE DYNAMIC?
>> THE FOCUS WAS ON THE
COMPREHENSIVE BILLS.
THERE WAS DISCUSSION ABOUT A
NARROW BILL.
THE SEPARATION ISSUE DID COME UP
A COUPLE TIMES, AND THE
PRESIDENT WAS VERY COMPASSIONATE
ABOUT IT, TALKED ABOUT HIS
DAUGHTER BRINGING THAT UP,
IVANKA.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT, IT'S NOT
LOST ON HIM THAT WE'VE GOT TO
FIX THIS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE'VE GOT
THIS FOR WEEK.